so you've called on Dominic Cummings to
go why do you think he needs to resign
if he doesn't resign we'll just keep
burning through Boris's political
capital at a rate that we just can ill
afford in the midst of this crisis it's
very clear that Dominic travelled when
everybody else understood Dominic's
slogans to mean stay at home protect the
NHS and save lives and I think mums and
dads who very much care about their
children and who have been foregoing the
child care of their extended family will
wonder why he's been allowed to do this
and I really just don't see as we
approach the prime minister at the
liaison committee on Wednesday now this
is going to go away unless Dominic goes
I mean the defense that's been mounted
by allies of Dominic Cummings is that
his wife was ill with coronavirus he was
worried that he was going to get ill
which he subsequently did and he was
trying to effectively protect the
well-being this child do you have any
sympathy with that argument of course we
couldn't have sympathy but I also am
aware that I represent tens of thousands
of people many of whom will have had
children and wives and husbands who were
ill with coronavirus and isolated at
home for seven days the first person 14
the others without travelling to get
better childcare and I can hold tough
single father in mind immediately who
stayed at home and didn't travel and you
know it's been extremely tough for those
people and I think yesterday secular
secretaries of state we're out there
with some quite thin lines trying to
save Dominic trying to change the
newspapers for today and it didn't work
and it isn't going to work because the
media aren't going to let this go
because of the way they've been sneered
at I'm afraid because of the way Dominic
conducts his politics and I just see
this rattling on now for day after day
wasting the public's time consuming
political capital and diverting from the
real issues we need to deal with no one
is indispensable
Dominic should go and we should have a
chief of staff to the Prime Minister who
doesn't end up in the newspapers in this
way you mentioned that the way that
Dominic Cummings conducts his politics
what exactly do you mean by that well
I've said this for a long time there's
two things about Dominic and I've said
it to him before and I've said it on the
record before the first is that he
creates an
awful lot of collateral damage we've
we've seen it before things like the
propagation he ends up he goes just that
little bit too far and attacks
institutions and people and it all just
it all just gets too uncomfortable and
it has consequences doubling down on the
bus for example during the campaign the
leaflet with Turkey things just get just
ugly around the edges and it has
collateral damage and consequences I'm
afraid it's yes it's important to win
but not at any cost it matters how you
win and I'm afraid Dominic does things
which I do not approve of if often
effective but they go too far and the
other issue which we saw with the vote
leave board in particular and we've seen
I think subsequently is Dominic just
really holds in contempt any any effort
to hold him accountable to others and
that's why I've always been opposed to
him being in number 10 I've obviously
had to do some difficult things in
politics but I've always made sure that
I was accountable to more senior
colleagues and I've seen with my own
eyes that Dominic won't do it as far as
I can tell the only person in politics
he respects is Michael Gove and he he
fights against any attempt to control
and more directive and so on and it's
just not a suitable way for anyone to
behave when they're in political life we
all have to be held to account at the
same time though many of the cabinet
backed him yesterday as far as we know
he still has the backing of the prime
minister why do you think Dominick
colleagues are so important clearly to
Boris Johnson
well it's first if I may on the
secretaries of state members of the
government of course they serve in the
government in a sense at Dominick's
pleasure I think everybody is very clear
that if Dominic this if you displease
Dominic you'd be leaving the government
briefed against as well but I don't
think that Dominic is indispensable to
Boris Dominic has always been very good
at taking over any organization he's in
he's an extremely cut accomplished
leader of his own team I've seen that
with my own eyes he he engenders a
heartfelt and ferocious loyalty he's
full of ideas often brilliant ones but
he is not always right he is certainly
not indispensable no one is after all
the graveyards are littered with people
who were indispensable he certainly if
we'd taken his strategic advice over the
course of the last two years we would
all think of destroyed the
Conservative Party lost power to Jeremy
Corbyn and if the deal had gone through
Parliament as he wanted we would have
banned ourselves into what Forrest
Johnson called vassalage so I'm very
grateful I didn't take his strategic
advice in the course of the time after
since I resigned from government but I'm
afraid I just think this is the end of
the road I objected to Dominic going
into number 10 on the day Boris became
prime minister my colleagues weren't
with me I think it's worked out badly as
it was bound to do I can understand why
Boris cut him in when it was a guerrilla
warfare stage at the beginning but now
that we're into serious governing with a
majority of 80 but Dominic's tactics are
out of place and he should go and this
moment has revealed that you know really
he has ended up not abiding by the
spirits at least of the slogans which he
has enforced on the rest of the country
about and the members of the cabinet who
gone in to back Dominic Cummings to
effectively say that he did something
that was understandable that wasn't
breaking the law that was the right
thing to do just to reflect on some of
the messaging that we've heard are you
concerned that the message that people
will now take from this is that the
rules laid down for the government on
lockdown are there to be interpreted
rather than followed well this is a
point I've made in the house of commons
you know we can't be in a situation
where there's uncertainty about what one
is obliged to do under law on penalty of
fines after all breaking the public
health lockdown rules is a criminal
offence if and if you get a you know you
go through and you get it you get it off
a record if you don't pay the fines if
you pay the fines it's not recordable
but this is this is the point this law
is being involved here to punish people
and to be in a position now where
there's extreme latitude in the
interpretation of the rules well that
makes them completely unenforceable for
the police I mean how are the police
supposed to enforce laws when they're
now subject to such wide interpretation
it means that a lot ban in law in
practice is virtually repealed it isn't
it I should say for the public it is not
in fact repealed but we're now in a
nonsense position of hands am I in
position where it seems that if you wish
to apply a wide common-sense
to predation of the rules you you can do
at least if you work in number ten it's
ridiculous it's got to stop and Dominic
should go